[Musik]
allerdings sieht auch mal waren bekamen
zu sommerloch und ja ich weiss nicht
total gut aus mit einem blumenkranz
wieder konnte mir sind vor schreck die
extension vorausgefahren jede machen wir
machen wollen wir da wurde geschrieben
hat ich meine haare und am ende war die
extensions wieder rausgehen man ich hab
auf youtube game einfach nicht verstand
klick klick klick klick war und meine
video und man könnte über aufgelegten
armee auf www.die wir fangen jetzt an
was gegen am wochenende ich habe am
wochenende natürlich wieder nicht meine
kamera ausgepackt aber ich habe auch
instanz die etwas hochgeladen und zwar
bei meiner freundin lisa 8 bei ihrer
tanzshow und das war super cool sound
[Musik]
damit solche show sieht oder einem
tanzfilm honey oder der bap und der
block 2 und 3 und 4
auf jeden fall möchte man dann auch mal
selber gleich los kämpfen meine mama hat
für heute trinkt viel wasser und nicht
wie aber vanessa das ist doch ganz schön
offensichtlich ja aber man kann es nicht
oft genug sagen was er ist auch wichtig
es ist gut für deine konzentration
es ist gut für dein stoffwechsel
allgemein dass du nicht einfach umkippt
motto geschichten auf der youtube welt
wenn man heiratet er sind maren und tobi
marin und tobi sind ein youtube auf
jeden fall bloggen wir ganz gut zusammen
und sie haben auch die hochzeit an die
hochzeit video online gestellt auf
youtube und ich wollte es möglich hassen
weil ich jetzt eigentlich nicht mag wenn
man sein ganzes privatleben so in die
öffentlichkeit so hoch aber ich konnte
dir das video einfach nicht hatten etwas
eine so schöne hochzeit video
da hat man gleich los heb zu heiraten
ich habe es nur gesehen und dachte mir
würde auch ein weißes kleid tragen und
blumen behandlung meinem freund und
familie bei mir und park und alle und
ansonsten auch keine interessanten infos
gefunden leon maschine hatten waffen
gekauft das könnt ihr euch noch erzählen
der mann jetzt waffenladen besitzer kann
dieser typ eigentlich noch seltsamer
sein was vielleicht wir eigentlich mit
waffenladen und wir nur extra den
letzten buchstaben falsch geschrieben
damit ihren ganzen homies wissen ist
dass der waffel laden ist wo man waffen
krieg denkt da mal drüber nach wie es zu
meinem
ich glaube meine nachbarn haben gerade
an die wand geklappt damit ich leise
aber wenn solche nachbarn eben halb eins
in der nacht pokerface von lady gaga
hört dann können wir auch mal meine
gesangseinlagen ertragen
[Musik]
sorry mein lieblingssong diese woche ist
auf dieser platte liebe euch eigentlich
komisch man sie brüder sind wände von
dahin eine community community manager
ist auf jeden fall das neue album ich um
mein bruder heißt das portieren war eine
richtig gute platte und meine
lieblingssongs sind gerade all right und
heiß da kann ich mich nicht ganz
entscheiden nicht zu kommen wir nun zu
meinen fargo will turn mit numero uno
kulturcafé verkauft hier und eines tages
ich da rein gelaufen und wollte etwas
milderes haben und dann meinte wieso
werde kult beruf werde ich lecker und
werde es mehr ganz ehrlich ich verfluche
die verkäuferin bis heute das minus ging
angedreht hat weil seitdem beständig
nichts anderes mehr
und ich hab da ständig bock drauf an
damit wie man so richtig schön basic aus
mein gott meine mama möchte mir nicht
das neue iphone 7 kaufen
favorit nummer zwei diese veganer
nutella die keine nutella ist sondern
muss nur creme aber sie ist so gut wie
nutella und ja vielleicht nicht exakt
genauso gut aber wie ist richtig richtig
gut und sie vegan und das war nicht ohne
da ist auch mal gut für die umwelt weiß
ich ganz genau warum aber paar müller
habe ich mal gehört
in den kommentaren wird wahrscheinlich
schon erklären warum teil wenig wut und
die wut bei denn's biomarkt gefunden ich
weiß jetzt merkt man band biomarkt lf
biomarkt ich weiß nicht was heißt denn
hier wird man meinen körper wird zu
einem dritten favorit und zwar firma
pflanzen ohne witz ich habe mir vor paar
tagen zimmerpflanzen geholt und zeigt
dass mein firma irgendwie so viel urlaub
gemüt mich ja schöner
das hat dieses gefühl hat zuletzt nicht
so richtig viel schulmäßig ist wurde ich
zum abtanzen
es gibt ein total wohlig warmes gefühl
in meiner hose machen wir lieber peter
diese kategorie hieß eigentlich aktuelle
waffeln für weniger versorgen will
und keinen interessiert ding da mir der
name aber klar habe ich es in news wanne
umgeändert aloha wertet und ladies und
gentlemen und freunde der leistung
seiner leitung willkommen bei uns waren
natürlich gibt es hier die spannendsten
und putzen und besten news auf der
ganzen welt bild wird der bild war es
gerade wirklich die melodie aus blues
clubs blauen schlau erwachsen
werd erwachsen herzen baby aus motorraum
gesetzes also in hessen
da ist ein mann zur autowerkstatt
gefahren weil der komische geräusche aus
seinem auto gehört hat und dann hat der
mann in der autowerkstatt geguckt und im
motorraum hat er dann ein katzenbaby
gefunden und das hat er dann gerettet
und wird ahnt sie dann mercedes genannt
davon erstmal genug für heute leistung
wieder kind sein
die heutige folge brauche ich ein blatt
papier din a4 blatt was ich gerade habe
sind rechnungen das ist tauchen ich
möchte nicht wieder kinder in der
heutigen ausgabe wieder kind sein
basteln wir uns dieses papier ding womit
man die zukunft vorhersagen konnte dafür
brauchen wir eine handelsübliche platz
abnehmen das blatt papier und falten ist
einmal so lang dann klagen wir es wieder
auf und falten an anderen ecken lang
jetzt haben wir hier zwei punkte und sah
mir das glas papier halten wird und
streifen da weckt zweifel und den teil
müssen wir abschneiden weil wir ein
quadratisches papier brauchen jetzt
halten wir einmal hier so in die
mittelrhein also jeder ecke wird in die
mittelrhein gefightet
das ist so aussieht dann drehte um und
teile des wieder in die mittelrhein
doch dort wo ihr gerade in die mitte
reingefeiert habt ihr das jetzt so
zusammen und dann klappte es wieder auf
und fans noch mal auf der anderen seite
zusammen und jetzt könnt ihr unten ein
platzen des informel arbeit wirklich
cool und da konnte man einem sachen
brauch schreiben und dann hier rein so
zahlen und so und dann konntest du damit
die zukunft vorhersagen ob ihr kennt das
wahrscheinlich alle ende jetzt mein
gesicht wieder überlegt nun zu unserer
twitter frage ich habe ihn gefragt was
wäre der werbeslogan für euer leben und
eure antworten anais league play off
what the pyjama also beschweren kann ich
mich da eher weniger oliver nennt leicht
obwohl du dick bist essen macht die
paula prosport aber eher nicht so wie
kann ich aber davon ganz schön viel
könnte besser sein
dafür ist es kostenlos michael winter
hier mir essen geht sandra täglich grüßt
das murmeltier nara whitewall in love
you can von michael eine unberührte
quelle youtube die wütete versuchungen
obwohl es schokolade gibt fabian doping
judith danke für die ganzen tollen
antworten ich konnte leider nicht alle
nehmen es waren zu viele aber wenn ihr
die nächste frage nicht verpassen wollt
dann folgt mir auf twitter und auf
instagram folgt mir einfach überall
leute das macht so spaß ein spaß für die
ganze familie damit wünsche ich euch
eine tolle woche ich hab' ich hatte
schon mal aufgefallen und wenn ja dann
einmal daumen nach oben und schreibt mit
passanten die kommentare
das video mit euren freunden familie
oder nachbarn den vielleicht nicht bin
gefällt das vielleicht nicht so aber
ansonsten y playlist videos abonnieren
nicht vergessen
eure basic mit vanessa ich könnte mir
gerade selber ins gesicht geschlagen